marine le pen invitée cette semaine de
preuves par 3 bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous le climat politique vous
profite dit on à la crise économique et
sociale s'ajoute la crise morale
mais attention à vous n'êtes pas la
seule à vouloir remporter la mise
marine le pen toutes les questions vous
seront donc posée lors de cette émission
créée par trois en partenariat avec l'
agence france-presse
représenter ce soir dans un instant par
andré abdominaux en partenariat
également avec dailymotion qui permet
aux téléspectateurs de vous interpeller
perrine tarneaud de public sénat nous
rejoindra comme chaque semaine à la fin
de cette émission les mots sont forts
du côté de l'exécutif sévérité mesures
draconiennes lutte contre la fraude
fiscale transparence des patrimoines est
ce que vous croyez au plan de lutte pour
la moralisation de la vie politique
c'est dire que je pense que la
multiplication de ces annonces cherche
en réalité à éteindre le feu
voilà le feu qui n'a peut être pas
terminé de brûler d'ailleurs en
l'occurrence parce que il semblerait
qu'un certain nombre de journaux se
fasse la course à l'échalote pour
recréer une espèce de feuilleton où
chaque jour apporterait son lot de
révélations
parce que surtout il ya des grosses
affaires qui sont actuellement
l'instruction quand même 1 et qui touche
le monde politique
je pense à la sphère de karachi je pense
à la sphère libyenne et d'autre et par
conséquent mais ça n'est qu'une longue
suite enfin je veux dire ça date pas
d'aujourd'hui
la sphère cahuzac n'est pas un élément
une anecdote dans la vie politique
française
la vème république a été frappé par une
suite ininterrompue de ce qu'on a une
suite ininterrompue d'affaires plus ou
moins graves mais qui il faut bien le
dire ont arrosé l'ump et le ps de
manière à peu près égales dans ce choc
de moralisation été annoncée par le chef
de l'état parfois ministre ne vous fera
pas renoncer à votre demande
de dissolution de l'assemblée nationale
rien enfin côté je vois le premier
ministre démissionnaire du gouvernement
le premier ministre organise une réunion
pour parler de la moralisation de la vie
politique
d'accord il invite les présidents de
groupe à l'assemblée nationale il a bien
choisi précisément les présidents de
groupe pour éviter quoi pour éviter
d'inviter le front national ça pose
quand même un problème comment vivait-on
parler de moralisation si déjà au départ
on n'a pas la morale élémentaire de
respecter les 20% de français qui ont
voté pour le front national a demandé au
chef du gouvernement
je demande la moindre des choses c'est
de montrer que les choses ont changé
parce que le simple fait de se réunir de
faire de l'entretoit comme ils sont en
train de le faire dans le cadre de ce
débat sur la moralisation démontre que
rien n'a changé
et s'il fallait une preuve que rien ne
changera il ya elle est apportée par
jean marc ayrault
avec cette décision que je trouve
absolument inouïe publier son patrimoine
vous n'êtes pas encore entreront oui
mais je ne suis pas content je les fais
d'ailleurs pendant l'élection
présidentielle
mais le fait de publier son patrimoine
n'a pas de sens ce qui est intéressant
c'est de pouvoir faire une comparaison
entre le patrimoine au moment où vous
accédez à votre mandat et le patrimoine
lorsque vous quittez votre mandat ou
lorsque vous les classes en public c'est
un patrimoine maintenant ce sera donc
public sera sur la table
donc ça ça n'est absolument pas
contestable mais je pense qu'il ya des
choses beaucoup plus importantes et
urgentes à mettre en scène la pub le
plus prioritaire c'est de se mettre en
place ce que j'avais proposée dans le
cadre de mon projet présidentiel
à savoir la mise en oeuvre d'une
commission denquête qui dans les membres
seraient désignés par le président du
sénat et le président de l'assemblée
nationale dont l'objectif serait
d'opérer une enquête préalable avant
toute nomination à des postes
d'importance dans la république est
évidemment avant toute nomination de
ministres dans le but de quoi de faire
une analyse du parcours professionnel de
voir s'il existe des conflits d'intérêts
qui rendrait critiquable le l'exercice
his politique de cette personnalité à la
place à laquelle on envisage alors de le
mettre les conflits d'intérêts vous êtes
avocate
mais s'il faut intervenir laitiers
est-ce qu'il faut interdire un
parlementaire de demeurer avocat
fortiori de le devenir durant son mandat
non je ne le crois pas je crois on
touche vraiment de conflit d'intérêts
souvent il a écouté il y a eu des mots
des perdants et son carnet d'adressés
parlement c'est comme ça que ça se passe
les deux les avocats puissent devenir
député narines non elle n'a rien de
critiquer ils sont d'ailleurs soumis à
un certain nombre d'interdictions ils ne
peuvent pas plaider par exemple dans les
affaires de droit de la presse
lorsqu'ils sont députés ils ne peuvent
pas plaider contre l'état tout ça a été
prévu ce qui est critiquable
ce sont les députés où les anciens
ministres qui réclament de devenir
avocat pour se servir du carnet d
adresses qui se sont constituées lors ce
qu'ils avaient des responsabilités
politiques
et pour vendre quelque sorte leurs
influences sont sous la robe arrêté sous
la robe d'avocat mais ça c'est le rôle
du du du conseil de l'ordre
c'est le rôle du barreau de faire le
ménage et de refuser ce type de démarche
et ces gens là n'ont bien souvent pas de
cabinet il met juste le roman sur et sur
une plaque
ils n'ont pas réellement d'activité
professionnelle d'avocat et ils ont
uniquement à wana une activité de trafic
en quelque sorte d' influence donc c'est
aux barreaux afin d'affirmer on trafique
l'influent sont bien là voilà je me sers
des gens que j'ai connu quand j'étais
ministre ou premier ministre et c'est
pour aider à la réalisation de telle ou
telle affaire c'est pas ça dans une
démocratie mais ça encore une fois ses
taux c'est au conseil de l'ordre des
avocats de d'être plus exigeant dans la
manière dont ils acceptent comme ça j'en
passe droit non mais non mais de son
suit vous ferez toutes les lois que vous
ce serait une habitation concret
regardez dans toutes les lois qui ont
été proposées laquelle aurait empêché
d'affaires cahuzac aucune aucune bon
parce qu'il ya aussi la morale voix
contre le mensonge bien voilà il ya
aussi la morale des hommes n'ont pas si
le sentiment d'impunité qui est un peu
celui il faut bien le dire de la classe
politique française
on a ce sentiment que de toute façon
rien ne peut arriver et que par
conséquent par conséquent on peut
continuer il ya le problème des
contrôles
moi j'aimerais savoir par exemple les
journalistes pourraient poser la
question à tous les députés
combien de députés ont eu un contrôle
fiscal dans leur vie c'est intéressant
de savoir ça non monsieur cahuzac n'y a
pas eu par exemple pas une seule fois
dans toute sa carrière il n'a eu de
contrôle fiscal
on ne vivrait pas formés j'en suis
absolument reconnaissait son avocat un
jour sur mars
j'en suis absolument convaincu alors que
par exemple je vous donne un exemple
mais jean marie le pen y en a eu 17
bon ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
le contrôle fiscal est utilisé depuis
des années non pas pour contrôler en
réalité l'activité fiscal des
responsables éventuellement politiques
ou des élus entre autres comme n'importe
quel autre d'ailleurs
comment dire français mais il est
utilisé comme une arme politique contre
les adversaires bon là aussi c'est une
dérive
incontestablement c'est une dérive est
ce que la lutte contre l'évasion fiscale
et pour vous également une autre des
priorités mais c'est une priorité comme
la lutte contre contre avérés contre
toute les façon occulte à l'étranger des
français mais contre toutes les fraudes
l'elcom la fraude sociale france il ya
un moyen très simple c'est de mettre en
place les mêmes conditions qui existent
par exemple aux états unis qui ont été
mises en oeuvre par le gouvernement
américain à savoir que dans le cadre
d'accord on dit va écouter tout ce qui
est en réalité vont dans un autre pays
pour payer moins d'impôts seront quand
même tenu de payer la différence au pays
dont ils ont la nationalité européenne
est aujourd'hui qu'on verra un compte à
l'étranger n'est pas anodin et ouvrir un
compte à l'étranger est totalement
anodin après si je ne comprends plus
mais monsieur ouvrir un compte à
l'étranger est anodin si vous déclarez
les sommes qui y sont à votre
administration fiscale c'est rare
surtout quand mais ça c'est moi mais sa
cellule mais ça c'est vous qui le dites
mais ça n'est pas vrai il ya des gens
qui ont des activités à l'international
qui ont des comptes à l'étranger et qui
déclare ses comptes à l'étranger à
l'administration fiscale française
honteux pas non plus créer un procès
d'intention parce que voilà sinon on
tombe dans quelque chose à mon avis pour
le coup également de critiquable bon il
ya un autre problème sur la moralisation
de la vie politique c'est que la
meilleure le meilleur contrôle qui est à
effectuer c'est celui de l'opposition
le problème de la vie politique
française et qui a plus d'opposition
en réalité ces deux partis que sont
l'ump et le ps ont tellement gouverner
ensemble pendant longtemps un coup c'est
toi un coup c'est moi qui l' impulsion à
coup c'est toi un coup c'est moi qui
signe la majorité que est ce que le
contrôle est vraiment effectué moi je me
rends bien compte que dans les conseils
régionaux le fait d'avoir une position
extrêmement efficace et même parfois
féroce oblige
l'exécutif à faire particulièrement
attention à ce qu'il fait et les
habitudes comprend avec le temps ne pas
tout à fait respecté les procédures etc
et bien quand on a une position digne de
ce nom eh bien ces procès procès ces
procédés ça reste un bon moyen de
moraliser aussi la vie publique
on sait c'est de baisser de permettre
que l'ensemble des français soient
représentés à l'assemblée nationale et
au sénat
ça a quand même rien d'extraordinaire et
même deux éléments conjugués un trou
bleu marine le pen notamment je citais
l'avocat philippe pena qui est un bon
proche proche du front national qui a
ouvert le compte de jérôme cahuzac en
suisse 1 en 1990 et nous en avait pas
parlé mais excusez moi non je n'en aie
pas dû le faire à partir de mon il y
avait par exemple n'aura pas dû le faire
à la justice s'exprimer à partir mans où
une information saisie de l'enquêté
préliminaire avait agi rapidement et
vous connaissez ce que c'est je le
secret professionnel
oui mais rédaction la justice américaine
mais monsieur vient d'être nommé
monsieur permettez moi il est avocat il
est couvert par le secret oblige mêmes
soumis d'ailleurs au secret
professionnel
qu'est-ce que ça des mais en quoi ce que
je comprends pas à part essayer de ne
rien que de citer mon nom dans une
affaire dans laquelle je ne suis
strictement pour rien ni de près ni de
loin
en quoi a servi cette règle soit disant
révélations effectuées de la part du
monde dont on sait que c'est un
journaliste un journal qui est un peu
spécialisés des manipulations politiques
lorsque ça la range d'ailleurs en quoi
ça apporter quelque chose au débat à
part qu'on apprenne que monsieur cahuzac
ad avec des amitiés mais justement aller
bien au delà
donc si on le sait les saisir et
politique
ah bon vous savez que ces deux questions
abondent mais sauf que moi je les
panneaux mais monsieur cahuzac
non mais c'est trop facile ça vous
mettez en cause parce que quelque part
ces mises en cause de ma probité en moi
je tiens beaucoup à la probité
voyez-vous bon et à ma réputation et par
conséquent je vous rappelle que mêmes et
si je l'avais su qu'est ce que j'aurais
dû faire monsieur faire une conférence
de presse pour dire monsieur cahuzac à
un con
un ami me l'a dit mais j'aurais été
immédiatement frappé par l'opprobre
généralisée de la classe politique
kim aurait d'ailleurs appliquer la
jurisprudence luc ferry quand monsieur
ferry a dit mais moi j'ai su qu'un
ministre avait eu des relations
sexuelles avec des enfants au maroc
mais qu'est-ce qui l'avait pas dit on
lui a dit mais comment les preuves etc
etc
ça n'est pas notre travail bon donc je
vais citer le monde le monde qui a
publié récemment vous avez peut-être
regarder ça avec intérêt toutes les
toutes les données de l'offshore leaks
aujourd'hui ce journal qui semble
détenir cent trente noms de français
ayant des comptes à l'étranger doivent
publier cette liste et de till dawn et
cette liste à l'administration fiscale
comme le demande bernard cazeneuve
qu'est ce qu'on pense qu'il serait plus
logique qu'il le donne à
l'administration fiscale
bon à mon sens parce que quand il doit
le faire bah oui
ne serait ce que parce que
l'administration fiscale va ainsi
pouvoir déterminer qui est
éventuellement coupable et qui ne l'est
pas parce que la publication brut de des
non sens en même que d'ailleurs les gens
qui soient sur cette liste que plus de
fois blement les français ne connaissent
pas pour l'immense majorité d'entre eux
parce que moi quand je vois le monde
dira oui on a sorti le nom est pourtant
voyez je peux être pas pour ma paroisse
à ça on a sorti le nom de monsieur j
parce que il avait du sens abonde donc
c'est le monde qui détermine les noms
qui ont du sens ou qui n'ont pas de sens
bon on n'est quand même pas très loin de
la nuit on n'est quand même pas très
loin de la manipulation politique à m
donc il faut être prudent et je pense
qu'il faut qu'ils transmettent à ce
moment à la justice entre un temps
semblé mois dans la charte de
déontologie des journalistes avaient
marqué que le journaliste ne doit pas ni
se prendre pour un policier ni pour un
juge
il me semble comprenez l'inégibilité à
vie des élus qui ont été condamnés dans
les affaires c'est bien ça qui ont été
condamnés dans l'exercice ou à
l'occasion ou grâce à leur mandat
alors pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
rencontré gaston flosse en polynésie
vous ignoriez à ce moment là qu'il avait
été condamné
enfermé je sais pas où il a été condamné
sauf que monsieur moi j'ai pas beaucoup
on n'a pas beaucoup de choix en
polynésie il ya en gros deux candidats
qui semblent être au second tour enfin
prévoir d'être au second tour il ya
monsieur flosse condamné d'un côté et
c'est vraiment pas ma tasse de thé
souhait ce que je veux dire un grand ami
d'ailleurs de jacques chirac et de
l'autre côté un indépendantiste alors eh
bien moi j'assume mes responsabilités et
j'ai dit comme certain nombre d'autres
on me passant le nez j'ai dit le diable
avec des cornes
à partir du moment où ils s'opposent à
un indépendantiste qui vise à éloigner
définitivement la polynésie des bras de
la république française
eh bien je préfère le diable avec des
cornes est ce que vous êtes en
compétition au moins pour les formules
avec jean luc mélenchon
vous avez entendu purification coup de
balai ce que vous allez finir par lui
réclamer le droit d'auteur non mais ce
que je n'utilise jamais ces termes là
jamais les termes de la violence de
monsieur mélenchon je n'ai pas
l'habitude de puiser mon vocabulaire
dans le bestiaire dans lequel
systématiquement monsieur mélenchon
puise les siennes
j'ai eu droit moi vous me direz c'est ce
m'améliore je suis passé de la campagne
présidentielle de chacals à caniche jean
voyez donc c'était ça c'était rien bon
mais on tape dans le vocabulaire
bestiaire je suis passé de 2,2
de shaka laka niche donc jusqu'à quand
même une amélioration
et puis et puis encore une fois il ya un
problème de sincérité je gère quid de
quelqu'un qui a quand même passé 30 ans
ps quoi et qui aujourd'hui cherchent à
faire oublier ce passé là et cherche à
se dédouaner de la responsabilité d'un
parti qui a quand même eu aussi accumulé
un certain nombre de 2,2 de critiquer
pas beaucoup de vocabulaire quand vous
entendez le patron des députés ump
christian jacob a qualifié le premier
ministre ayant même désir de repris de
justice est ce que vous estimez qu'il
s'aventure sur des terres dangereuses
non non c'est vraiment c'est vrai vous
voilà des gens quand même qu'ils sont un
travail je suis désolé moi enfin écoutez
c'est quand même étonnant mois on vient
me demander de me justifier ce quelque
chose dont je sais absolument pas
coupable d'un de mes amis qui aurait
quand je le connaissais pas il ya 25 ans
ouvert un compte à son client monsieur
cahuzac et en ange quelqu'un qui a été
condamné il ya 15 ans mais qui est
premier ministre
quelqu'un qui est à la tête du parti
société a été condamné deux fois
récidiviste quand même à cela on ne
pourrait pas leur rappeler leur
condamnation
j'aimerais savoir pourquoi alors la
situation actuelle peut-elle être
comparé aux années 30 qui a vu la montée
des populismes la question revient
beaucoup avant d'accueillir elle revient
ou dans l'amont victimes à dans les
débats qui vous intéresse au premier
plan évidemment à loisir dans la mouche
elle revient dans la bouche de mes
adversaires politiques morts le gauche
qui en règle générale si vous voulez
quand ils savent plus quoi dire
on arrive immédiatement soit aux années
30 de manière générale aux années 30
alors c'est la réduction à d' hitler ou
mon général alors avant d'accueil andré
à bobino de leicester et comme à voir
quelle est la réalité est l'intérêt de
cette interrogation avec ce parallèle
historique qui est dressé pour nos par
alexandra coléno une crise monétaire des
krachs boursiers
la montée du chômage les scandales
politiques les images des années 30
ressemble à celle d'aujourd'hui
comme si l'histoire bégayait dans les
années 30 on était en france et ailleurs
encore dans le cadre d'un capitalisme
national
aujourd'hui l'économie
et totalement mondialisé fonctionne en
temps réel ce n'est évidemment pas les
mêmes contraintes les gouvernements qui
continue à gérer les choses à l'échelle
nationale sont hors de situations
d'influer sur deux mouvements qui passe
les frontières qui sont mondiaux et que
aucun état sauf s'il est de très grande
taille comme les états unis n'est en
mesure d'infléchir et par conséquence a
conduit évidemment à l'idée que les
gouvernements sont impuissants il faut
un grand coup de balai la question
serait donc la phase un système à bout
de souffle
la tentation d extrême est elle réelle
tap ont mené un vote aux extrêmes ça
peut mener ce qui n'est pas moins grave
à une sorte de désintérêt du politique à
une dérision du politique
le problème de la dérision me semble
quelque chose d'extrêmement grave même
si ça fait beaucoup rire les gens et je
prends parce que il remet en cause au
fond le l'attachement des citoyens la
démocratie et la tente qu'ils ont de
solution politique au problème qu'ils
connaissent
selon les derniers sondages 32% les
français se méfient des politiques 36%
ont du dégoût à la rencontre nous a
rejoints pour vous interroger
justement quelles différences vous de
vous tirer entre aujourd'hui les années
30 c'est ainsi mais d'abord je récuse
formellement et vous le savez
pertinemment puisque vous usez de cette
formulation de manière régulière dans
une démarche que je considère là aussi
comme une démarche politique monsieur
bambino de la fp le terme d'extrême
voilà je récuse formellement 7,7 ce
terme sont pas les seuls à son problème
ne sont pas les seuls mais ils honte à
une responsabilité peut être plus
importante que les autres
compte tenu de ce qu'est la fp voilà
c'est faut le dire un moment donné faut
dire les choses
pourquoi vous ne vous donne l'occasion
de nous expliquer pourquoi vous ne
seriez pas vraiment pourquoi serais-je
d'extrême droite tient et bien par
exemple la préférence nationale le fait
le fait de de prôner des discriminations
entre les français et les étrangers sur
le dr matis gouvernement d'extrême
droite alors dans le monde
le maroc et d'extrême droite la suisse
doit être d'extrême droite
l'ensemble des pays qui sont très
nombreux qui font une différence entre
les droits qu'ils accordent à leurs
nationaux et les droits qu'ils accordent
aux étrangers sont d'extrême droite il y
en a un certain nombre qui vont se
retourner
honnêtement sur leur siège la route
nationale a été fondée en 1972 notamment
par les néofascistes d'ordre nouveau qui
sont rassemblés autour de jean marie le
pen vous êtes vous avez mal lu votre ami
monsieur maistre du monde qui se dit
spécialiste de l'extrême droite qui ne
l'est pas mais enfin il se le dit
puisqu'en l'occurrence ordre nouveau à
quitter immédiatement le front national
justement et pour une raison simple
monsieur c'est parce que un jour jean
marie le pen a dit bon écoute et tout ça
c'est bien gentil mais nous irons nous
arriverons pouvoir par les urnes nous
arriverons au pouvoir par le processus
démocratique et un certain nombre de
ceux qui espéraient le grand soir qui
est un petit peu l'équivalent si vous
voulez de l'extrême gauche et qu'ils
n'entendaient pas respecter les règles
la démocratie du coup l'ont quitté bon
ça les a menés pour certains c'est loin
puisque on en a retrouvé certains dans
des ministères dans les gouvernements de
monsieur sarkozy oui les gens l'occident
d'ordre nouveau enfin vous faites pas
d'étonner vous savez quand même
pertinemment que certains en son sens en
sont sortis comme un de ces types des
mouvements bon voilà nous sommes un
mouvement patriote nous attachons une
importance fondamentale à la nation nous
considérons que la protection de notre
peuple passe par l'existence de
frontières par la maîtrise de ses
frontières que ce soit pour la maîtrise
des flux migratoires la maîtrise
éventuellement des flux de capitaux ce
qui éviterait d'ailleurs un certain
nombre de problèmes et la maîtrise des
produits qui sont importés notamment
pour éviter la concurrence
internationale déloyale
nous sommes des démocrates c'est à nous
sommes pour un fonctionnement
démocratique absolue puisque comme vous
le savez nous sommes pour la
proportionnelle intégrale et pour le
référendum d'initiative populaire
donc on ne peut pas être plus tenant de
la démocratie que ce que nous sommes
nous réfutons sanou réfutant toute
action violente quelle qu'elle soit je
ne vois pas encore une fois ce qui
permet de nous positionner à l'extrême
droite et c'est si vrai monsieur marc
mineau qu' il y à une nomenclature qui
est effectuée par le ministère de
l'intérieur notamment pour les élections
et là il ya parti socialiste et c'est
l'ump front national extrême droite pas
briller une dernière question pour
terminer là dessus vous aviez
visiblement très envie de
de vous défendre sur ce point de
l'extrême droite c'est comme si vous
vouliez vous dire pourquoi je veux dire
pourquoi parce que il ya quelques jours
il ya quelques jours vous avez fait une
dépêche afp
en dix ans des militants d'extrême
droite ont brutalisé je ne sais plus qui
dans la sphère du mariage et voyez là je
me suis dit c'est mal ce que vous faites
parce qu'à force de dire que trois
seraient de l'extrême droite et après
parler de militants extrêmement dont
vous savez pertinemment qu'ils ne sont
pas au front national
vous créez de la malle gagnent dans
l'esprit de ceux qui vous lisent et par
conséquent vous ne participez pas à la
scène d'informations auxquelles vous
devriez à laquelle deux prix soit les
actions commando de certains opposants
mais julien monde tout ce qui passe par
la violence c'est clair je l' ai
toujours fait et est le monsieur en
question
je les fichus à la porte du front
national du front national à merci il
n'y a aucun doute là-dessus marine le
pen vous n'hésitez jamais attaqué les
journaux en diffamation quand les noues
santé bafoués pourquoi sur ce terme
d'extrême droite s'il est si choquant
vous n'attaquez pas les journées en
diffamation ab parce que cher monsieur
j'ai fait de nombreux droits de réponse
sur ce sujet mais une grande bataille
judiciaire
mais la diffamation répond à des
conditions extrêmement précises qui ne
permettent pas de poursuivre en
diffamation sur ce thème d'extrême
droite voilà c'est malheureux mais c'est
ainsi la diffamation c'est l'atteinte à
la considération à à l'honneur et ça
doit faire l'objet d'une preuve
donc c'est un fait qui peut faire ce
qu'il doit pouvoir faire l'objet d'une
preuve ce qui n'est pas le cas de ce
terme j'aimerais tellement pouvoir le
faire monsieur bambino mais on va
revenir sur l'europe on va parler
d'europe vous avez réclamé un référendum
sur la fin de l'union européenne cet
appel a un peu fait réagir dans la
classe politique comment vous expliquer
ce faible écho pour l'instant est bien
en tout cas je peux vous dire qu'il ya
eu un très fort écho dans les autres
pays européens
voilà incontestablement cette
proposition d'un référendum et d'un
référendum que j'aimerais voir organisé
dans l'ensemble des pays de l'union
européenne car je tiens que les peuples
européens se font imposer une union
européenne auquel en réalité in ont pour
beaucoup d'entre eux pas adhéré et bien
affaire
beaucoup débattre a fait beaucoup
discuté dans beaucoup de pays européens
pourquoi il n'ya pas d'écho enfants mais
pour une raison simple c'est que nous
avons l'intégralité de la classe
politique et européiste l'intégralité de
la classe politique est pour le fait de
non seulement de rester dans l'union
européenne mais de rester dans l'union
européenne telle qu'elle existe
évidemment de traiter que de droite et
de gauche sur le consom'acteur de leur
peau et bien sûr des critiques mais
comme ça puisse paraître la honte
éthique dans le canapé en prenant
l'apéro et on s'arrête là bon en réalité
parce que il n'ya jamais eu rien d'autre
que cela en critique pour faire plaisir
au bon peuple parce que le bon peuple
ils commencent à se rendre compte que
l'union européenne 1 il en a soupé que
l'union européenne le bilan d'une union
européenne est globalement négatif alors
on va sur les plateaux de télévision du
roule à l'europe il faut une autre robe
c'est pas bien faut changer l'europe
mais moi je les vois en parlement
européen les mêmes qui sont sur vos
plateaux de télévision et qui pour faire
plaisir au peuple de pensée critique
l'europe et ils votent l'intégralité de
ce qui constitue la colonne vertébrale
d'une union européenne plus la libérale
déjà récemment mais si coûteux apprécié
des négociations boutique mais le la
colonne vertébrale idéologique de
l'union européenne n'a jamais été remise
en cause et c'est si vrai monsieur que
le simple terme de protectionnisme est
un gros mot vous n'avez pas le droit de
parler de protectionnisme dans
l'enceinte du parlement européen
vous avez immédiatement tous les
responsables qui poussent des hauts cris
en faisant mon dieu tout sauf le
protectionnisme d'hommes imaginons qu'il
ait lieu
les français votent oui la france en de
l'union européenne quelle certitude vous
avez que ça met fin vraiment
véritablement à l'union européenne si la
france s'en sort parce que je crois que
l'union européenne ne peut pas perdurer
persister sur la france voilà c'est
aussi simple que ça et c'est pour ça que
d'ailleurs que je trouve absolument
malheureux que la france ne soit pas
capable de défendre ses propres intérêts
auprès de l'ambiance est un plus
c'est vrai c'est un pilier de l'europe
mais on n'est plus dans l'europe à 6
soit 12 en aidant l'europe à 27 mais
parce que 26 pays
même s'écrouler mais elle peut aussi ne
pas s'écrouler vous avez mesurer ce
risque dans un autre projet non mais je
ne crois pas une demi-seconde que
l'union européenne puisse survivre sans
la france d'autant que je pense que
beaucoup de peuples européens sont en
train de se détourner eux mêmes de
l'union européenne et que par conséquent
ils exigeraient eux mêmes
l'organisation de référendum auquel un
certain nombre de leurs dirigeants
seront soit heureux soit contraint de
céder j'ai fait dans vos pronostics
durant la campagne présidentielle vous
pronostiquez la fin de l'euro
l'explosion de l'euro c'est pourtant
sans appel j'ai eu à ça n'a pas eu lieu
dans les six mois qui nous séparent de
l'élection présidentielle mais vous
aviez vous même pronostiqué vous et vos
amis et les grands experts journalistes
que l'union européenne c'est c'est eh
ben on allait sauver l'euro c'est la
grèce était un exemple c'était un hasard
c'était une exception et puis il ya une
espagne et puis portugal et puis à hull
chypre et demain il y aura la slovénie
et par conséquent si vous voulez je
trouve que dans les prévisions que j'ai
pu faire sur la manière dont l'union
européenne se déroule
je suis beaucoup plus proche de la
réalité que ne le sont ce qu'ils sont
censés être beaucoup plus experts que
moi et qui sont en train de mener notre
pays et les autres pays d'ailleurs de
l'union européenne dans le mur un
chiffre l'union européenne représentent
60% des exportations françaises
est ce que vous pensez vraiment si la
france pour la responsabilité historique
de casser l'europe de casser l'union
européenne on protégera nos exportations
en europe et bien sûr le rapport rapport
met en effet excusé moi mais
donc nous exportons aujourd'hui c'est
parce qu'avant on exportait pas bon
c'est quoi casser des pierres on se
chauffait avec du feu de bois
on salue on s'illuminer à la lampe à
huile
on faisait quoi avant l'euro et avant la
construction très avancé l'union
européenne en exportait et on exportait
même beaucoup mieux la preuve d'ailleurs
c'est qu'on était en excédent
alors qu'aujourd'hui on a un déficit
absolument historique de l'europe on le
serait bien
ah c'est pas de valeur mais qu'est ce
que ça changerait mois les droits de
douane que je vais mettre en oeuvre que
les choses soient claires je veux les
mettre en oeuvre est payé en retour
mais non parce que je veux les mettre en
oeuvre avec des pays qui crée une
concurrence internationale déloyale avec
moi pas avec des pays qui ont à peu près
le même niveau économique que le mien
par conséquent je vais pas mettre des
droits de douane avec des pays comme
l'italie je vais en mettre en revanche
avec des pays comme la chine
sauf exception on va pas remettre avec
l'allemagne sauf peut-être sur leur
production de d'élevages de porcs ou là
clairement je considère qu'il ya une
rupture de la concurrence loyale puisque
ils viennent ils vont chercher du
personnel qu'il paye 300 ou 400 euros
par mois
et donc je considère qu'il l'a il ya une
rupture de concurrence il ya une sorte
de dumping social
à ce moment-là chirurgicalement
effectivement je mettrai en place des
droits de douane dans l'intérêt mais
dans l'intérêt des français est dans
l'intérêt de l'économie française hier
le front national a rendu hommage à
maria thatcher qu'est-ce que vous
admirez 7
je sais dirigeante et si je n'ai qu'une
chose à dire
j'admire profondément la manière dont
elle défend des en toutes circonstances
son pays
voilà encore très contre tout le monde
elle défendait les intérêts de son
peuple et de son pays il se trouve
qu'elle était un défenseur de la
souveraineté nationale je le suis aussi
donc ça nous fait un point commun bon il
ya un certain nombre d'autres domaines
selon lequel on était très certainement
en désaccord et roulera plus oui il
avait bien sûr mais ça pose pas vraiment
vous êtes en contradiction avec vous
même en soutenant marek massy et
marianne thatcher chante au libéralisme
social qui a défendu la loi du marché
c'était réglementation financière vous
dénoncez la mondialisation alors
messieurs georges oui oui mais moi j'ai
un cerveau dans quel et à sa bande de
cellules et j'essaie de pas avoir une
vision binaire
vous savez par exemple j'ai été j'ai
même été amenés non non il faut juste
être cohérent voilà et pas être
caricatural j'ai même été amené à dire
que je trouvais que chavez par exemple
avait fait des bonnes choses lorsqu'il a
fait profiter de la manne pétrolière
son peuple au lieu comme un certain
nombre d'autres de s'enrichir
personnellement lui et ses amis bon
j'essaye d'avoir une vision juste des
gens et il faut admettre que margaret
thatcher
défendez son pays et en cela et bien
elle a un petit côté d'exception
aujourd'hui
merci père il continuer à vous parler
échanger sur tous les sujets c'est
important perrine tanoh de tuniques cela
va nous rejoindre pour aborder
maintenant l'enjeu des municipales pour
vous puis les européennes
également vous labourer le terrain des
lille même les plus petites dans votre
camp certains et pas n'importe qui en
valent roy évoque des accords localement
avec des sortants ump fabrice canet au
front national comme à l'ump la ligne
politique est claire toute alliance est
exclu mais dans la perspective des
municipales de 2014
la réalité du terrain pourrait être
différent
il ya 143 communes dans le var et 150
fois que lui dans le var suis pas du
tout sûr dans certains endroits la
nécessité locale mais ça sera ça sera
quand un jean le var ou encore le
vaucluse la circonscription de marion
maréchal-le pen
pour elle les tractations auraient
commencé dans certaines communes il n'y
aura pas d'alliance de parti au niveau
national mais des éventuels union de
circonstance avec des gens qui nous
paraît sincère qui ont peut-être
derrière eux des bilans tout à fait
respectable et donc dans ce cas là avec
qui nous pourrons éventuellement nous
associer notamment en vaucluse où c'est
vrai qu'à une grande porosité entre les
électorats où nous sommes proches de la
france on va dire très à droite de l'ump
qui est majoritaire qui donne de ce fait
là pour être plus à même on va dire
trouver du soutien auprès de nous la
question d'une alliance entre l'ump et
le front national c'est un peu
l'arlésienne à chaque élection mais pour
la première fois depuis longtemps une
courte majorité de sympathisants ump se
disent favorables à un tel rapprochement
de quoi ouvrir la boîte à souvenirs ça
rappelle beaucoup l'atmosphère actuelle
à droite celle des années 1983 84
lorsque progressivement une partie du
rpr de l'udf de l'époque s'était
radicalisé et avait accepté notamment
lors des municipales de fondre les
listes à l'époque les sympathisants des
partis de la droite classique
voyez en dans front national beaucoup
plus un ailier qu'un concurrent
aujourd'hui la donne a changé les deux
formations se disputent le leadership à
droite et le front national se cherche
une assise locale alors l'ump a déjà
prévenu ses candidats aux municipales de
en cas d'accord ce sera l'exclusion le
président le sujet donc pas d'alliance
nationale avec les partis mais peut-être
des alliances de circonstances possibles
au niveau local oui elle a exprimé sa de
manière très claire et pas seulement
d'ailleurs avec éventuellement des gens
de l'ump
il peut y avoir il ya aussi moi j'ai des
discussions au sinon j'ai discussions
avec des gens de divers droite y en a
beaucoup et même mêmes ya des
discussions et légendes divers gauche
oui ça devrait pas vous étonner après la
parcelle de l'oise 1 il ya quand même
des gens qui considèrent que la
politique menée par le gouvernement ne
leur va pas du tout qui sont des
patriotes et qui considère que dans le
cadre de la gestion municipale
eh bien il ya moyen de pouvoir sur la
base sur la base d'une charte en quelque
sorte politique avec des points
essentiels
ce maître se mettre d'accord mais ça
restera l'exception car quelle est la
règle axemen municipalité à votre avis
ses amis anciens policiers mais je ne
sais pas pour écouter mais on est à un
an des municipales
qu'est ce que je peux venir vous dire
comme président du front national que
l'exception ce sera ça que quand même la
règle c'est que nous présenterons nous
partirons avec des listes front national
rassemblement bleu marine et que et que
effectivement nous serons présentes dans
un très grand nombre de listes j'espère
d'ailleurs dans un score historiquement
haut de liste aux municipales avec
l'espérance d'avoir des mers et d'avoir
des centaines de conseillers municipaux
parce que c'est ça notre but mais
gilbert collard lui il dit ne faut pas
faire élire un socialiste est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec cette ligne
c'est à dire que franchement avec ce
qu'ils font actuellement le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est que se baladait avec
l'étiquette socialiste c'est quand même
pas la meilleure des étiquettes c'est
quand même le mettez dans votre charte
pour accepter un des voix là des choses
qui à mon avis des élus socialistes
n'accepterons pas on va par exemple m le
l'arrêt de l'augmentation des impôts
locaux
on va mettre l'arrêt des subventions aux
associations communautaristes bon par
exemple voilà des choses qui à mon avis
ils vont exactement l inverse de la
boutique est menée par le parti
socialiste mais qui vont aussi à la
verve d'un petit qui est mené par un
très grand nombre
hélas d'élus ump mais si on prend
l'exemple précis par exemple la ville de
marseille où vous serez sans doute en
position d'arbitré qui vous allez
soutenir pour la mainitien stéphane
ravier le candidat front national
rassemblement bleu marine au risque de
faire peut-être basculé seconde ville de
france à gauche a hobo voyons c'est trop
facile
ben non c'est lui c'est à mon avis c'est
le candidat de l'ump qui en se
maintenant pas prendre ce risque là
c'est pas nous c'est à dire c'est le
processus démocratique
parce qu'à ce moment là il ya plus de
démocratie on considère que le
bipartisme est imposé par la loi
un qui à l'ump d'un côté et le ps de
l'autre et que les autres n'ont pas le
droit de se présenter je dire si les
électeurs n'ont plus envie ni de l'ump
ni du ps il ya quand même des éléments
il ya quand même des raisons bon or je
pense que nous pouvons apparaître comme
étant la véritable force d'alternative à
un système dont à mon sens beaucoup de
lecteurs ont fait le tour est ce que
vous espérez que le front républicain
contre le front national se fissure un
peu plus comme on l'a vu lors de la
parade lors de la législative partielle
dans l'oise existe plus ce front
républicain pour autant votre candidate
n'a pas gagné dans l'oise d'accord est à
l'affût 48 ennemis quoi ok pas gagné
mais enfin elle aurait pu à bord vous en
êtes d'accord dont ce fameux plafond de
verre dont tout le monde parlait à
sauter la réalité c'est que les
consignes qui sont données par les
appareils ne sont pas suivies par les
électeurs voilà les français ils ont
envie de se déterminer eux mêmes ils ont
pas envie qu'on leur donne des consignes
et surtout quand il ne les comprennent
pas parce que je veux dire il ya
beaucoup d'électeurs de l'ump notamment
qui comprennent pas les consignes
d'exclusive de l'ump à notre égard ils
peuvent très bien considérer qu'on est
en désaccord sur l'europe par exemple on
a une vision très différente mais ils
comprennent pas pourquoi on leur demande
de voter pour un socialiste plutôt que
pour un candidat front national je veux
dire ça leur paraît ahurissant et
d'ailleurs il faut bien le dire que le
niveau des explications qui sont données
par les responsables ump sont pas très
convaincante
le mariage pour tous la discussion se
poursuit cette semaine au sénat
vous n'avez pas participé aux
manifestations contre le projet de loi
est ce que ça veut dire que si vous
arrivez au pouvoir vous ne reviendrai
pas en arrière sur sa taille tout à fait
je reviendrai tout à fait ça pour rien
volé à la différence de l'ump
que je parle de ma forme je ne s'agit
plus de manière plus efficace
je reviendrai sur ce texte serait même
si le retour en arrière seront
difficiles à partir du moment où des
mariages et je reviendrai sur ce texte
dans le cadre de l'état de droit c'est à
dire que ceux qui auront été mariée le
resteront mais qu'il n'y en aura pas
d'autre nicolas sarkozy au plus haut
chez les sympathisants ump 63% le
préfère comme candidat en 2017 contre
tous les autres à droite vous avez donc
des risques de le retrouver sur votre
chemin en 2017 je ne crois pas non non
ce que je ne trouve pas il a dit qu'il
se déciderait si vous vous représenter à
nouveau un danger en 2010
ah mais ce sera avant ou après avoir
monté son grand fonds d'investissement
avec le qatar il a démenti sa a il l'a
démenti
bon gras avenir en politique je suis
convaincu qu'il ne reviendra pas en
politique
mais ce que ce ce nom mais je suis
convaincu du tout pour cause mais je
suis aussi réjouie ce n'est pas pure
invention mais en suis convaincu c'est
vrai j'ai défendu sur wii par exemple il
sera sûrement politique c'est important
aussi l'intuition et mais en revanche je
suis convaincu d'une chose c'est que en
laissant penser qu'il va revenir il
il ne rend pas service à ses amis car
enfin si nicolas sarkozy apparaît comme
un recours
ça veut dire que ni jean françois copé
ni françois fillon ne sont capables de
susciter une adhésion dans leur propre
électorat
nicolas c'est quand même un tout petit
peu problématique pour eux quand même
mais il reste du chemin jusqu'en 2017
vous avez tout à fait raison de le
rappeler
s'ils tentaient que d'ici là il n'est
pas une dissolution de l'assemblée
nationale
comme je l'espère et comme commencent à
l'évoquer un certain nombre d'analystes
politiques
on l'a réclamée avec force parce que
vous êtes sûrs d'être ministre forcément
après des élections non je la réclame
je la réclame et je l'organisent j'ai
d'ailleurs demandé à mes mais promis je
vais demander à mes services de de
prévoir
l'organisation effectivement de
législatives anticipées de prévoir le
calendrier que ce serait celui de notre
mouvement politique
dans le cas d'une dissolution de
l'assemblée nationale en traitement avec
les candidats sur le terrain près être
tout à fait avec les candidats pré sur
le terrain avec le travail commencé sur
les documents de campagne sur voilà
l'organisation que nécessitent des
législatives effectivement organisé dans
des temps beaucoup plus rapide que les
élections classiques vous vous préparez
à la fonction oui bien sûr mais ça date
pas d'hier matin monsieur ont porté sur
des questions d'actualité sur la
consommation de cannabis le ministre de
l'intérieur veut punir les consommateurs
d'une simple contravention est ce que
vous considérez que c'est un premier pas
vers la dépénalisation du cannabis
bien sûr je crois surtout que la
multiplication des signes de laxisme que
donne le ministre de l'intérieur au
moment où explose la sécurité est très
ennuyeuse parce qu'elle est entendue
évidemment comme un signal d'impunité
par les délinquants
donc le meilleur moyen si vous voulez de
lutter contre le trafic de drogue c'est
de lutter contre le trafic de drogue
du haut des réseaux jusqu'en bas c'est à
dire jusqu'au consommateur mais il faut
bien dire que les résultats de monsieur
valse sont pitoyables et donc qu'il mêle
la population française dans une
situation inquiétante lorsque l'on voit
l'explosion du nombre de cambriolages
lorsque l'on voit l'explosion du nombre
de délits commis par ces réseaux mafieux
nomades que 60 % + 60 % en ile-de-france
par rapport au mois de février de
l'année dernière pour le mois de février
2013 dans des villes moyennes de
province il ya des explosions de 60 à 80
% des cambriolages
rien ne semble être mis en oeuvre pour
lutter contre cette délinquance nomades
contre ces réseaux mafieux et c'est
évidemment très inquiétant pour la
population sur les roms à lyon le préfet
du rhône a été condamné à reloger dix
familles de roms faute de leur avoir
proposé des solutions d'accueil
convenable alors pour l'instant le
préfet n'a pas donné suite à cette
décision du tribunal administratif
vous comprenez qu'il traîne les pieds je
trouve cette décision absolument
scandaleuse et j'espère qu'elle aura le
plus large écho dans la population
française pour que les français
s'aperçoivent que aujourd'hui la loi
oblige à reloger des gens qui pour
l'immense majorité d'entre eux sont en
situation parfaitement illégal sur notre
territoire
non rien n'allait faire qui les
accueillent ces départs ouassara cas il
sait très bien parfait comme ça hue et
au mois ils peuvent mettre les actes de
charité à la suite de déclarations de
charité et que les français ne soient
pas prioritaire dans l'accès au logement
dans leur propre pays ma paraît délirant
c'est surtout très inquiétant pour
l'avenir car si on commence à faire ça
lorsque la bulgarie la roumanie verront
schengen autoriser les roms de roumanie
les roms de bulgarie et d'autres pays de
l'est pouvoir venir s'installer et avoir
la certitude d'être prioritaire dans
l'accès aux logements offerts par les
pouvoirs publics est bien très
honnêtement je souhaite bien du plaisir
aux différentes spécialités de
conditions actuelles les différents
départements
dernier point mais pour faire réagir des
rafale marine le pen j'ai dû ni tableau
de roland cayrol un célèbre politologue
qui dit que la moitié de vos électeurs
en fait ne se pas vous voir arriver aux
affaires il tire ça nous c'est un nombre
de sondages
je ne sais pas ce que ça vous interpelle
sur la crédibilité des solutions de vous
apporter
pas du tout non je ne crois pas du tout
à ce type d' analyse je pense que le
vote france est il devenu un vote
d'adhésion si tenté qu'il est était
exclusivement un vote de protestation ce
qui n'est absolument pas sûr et je
prends le français a certes je crois les
français tout de même intelligent et par
conséquent si vote pour quelqu'un c'est
a priori qu'il veut qu'ils veulent voir
appliquer évidemment ces idées merci
d'avoir est avec nous aujourd'hui
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation à une
peine merci bonsoir à tous et à très
vite
la france a atteint ses objectifs au
mali adm chef de l'état et chaque
français peut être fier du travail fait
par nos soldats alors quel état réel
aujourd'hui d'al qaïda et d'aqmi qui ont
perdu successivement abu zayd et ben
laden faut-il craindre pour nos otages
en tant de questions pour le docu débat
de la semaine sur public sénat le débat
présenté par benoît duquesne dimanche à
10h sur public sénat demain réd
en plein coeur de l'hiver la population
dans les alpes françaises peut être
multipliée par six des millions de
touristes partent à l'assaut des pistes
enneigées
quitte à mettre en péril les équilibres
naturels d'autres font le choix d'une
activité plus respectueuse de
l'environnement
ici le pas et dans le silence quasi
total isolement recherchés sur le
plateau de loi
la balade en raquettes offre un
spectacle préserver c'est un magnifique
panorama sur toute la haute savoie dans
360 c'est assez je dis donc c'est un
endroit qui est particulièrement riche
c'est un endroit qui est à peu près 1000
hectares et danser mes lecteurs il ya 70
% de forêts
ces spectateurs privilégiés recherche
autre chose que le ski à tout prix y'a
pas de remontées mécaniques et réactive
qui polluent la nature en fête donc
c'est juste qu'ils profitent de la
nature font état de plus simple quoi
dominique mère et guide accompagnateur
depuis 18 ans il est né dans les alpes
et il ya toujours vécu
on trouve plusieurs chouette les
chouettes de taille manège fait
chevêchette etc bref ça c'est un endroit
qui est riche et qu'il faut respecter
depuis des années il assiste au
grignotage de sa montagne la montagne
s'est morcelé on a des endroits sauvages
qu'on est arrivé à un peu dans comme
l'endroit dans lequel on évolue et à
d'autres endroits comme des réserves
naturelles où on a réussi quand même à
conserver favorablement les milieux il
fuit à d'autres mondes d'autres endroits
où la montagne se dégrade
j'en veux aux personnes qui ont détruit
ce que vous moi je peux pas découvrir
que j'ai pas pu découvrir ce que
j'arrive trop tard donc en se disant ça
c'est vrai que je voudrais laisser
montagne propre et qu'ils puissent voir
ce que ce que nous on peut voir encore
quoi dire ce que donne la nature à
l'état pur sur la faune ou la flore
c'est vrai qu'on peut voir des choses
extraordinaires des spectacles
impressionnants et j'aimerais quand même
qu'ils puissent qu'ils puissent voir ça
vitesse soleil poudreuse vin chaud
transat cocktail idéal d'un séjour au
ski
des milliers de skieurs et surfeurs
règne en maître et dévale les pentes de
la moyenne station des gets les alpes
françaises et ses quelques 250 stations
de ski eldorado des touristes européens
en quête de sensations fortes
mais ce déferlement de vacanciers abîme
la montagne façonné transformé pour les
accueillir
résultat une empreinte écologique forte
sur un milieu fragile et menacée depuis
une cinquantaine d'années la température
aurait augmenté entre 1 et 3 degrés dans
les alpes françaises
aux jets on tente de limiter l'impact du
domaine sur l'environnement alors elodie
pourquoi avoir installé ce panneau
solaire à concerne alors c'est très
simple en fait une moue sur domaine on
communique par radio les puissants
notamment les méridiens caylar
d'installer nouvelle antenne va plus
pour ses radios si elle est certaine
dans l'ombre et donc les panneaux
solaires ont permis afin de permettre
d'alimenter à l'antenne on avait fait
citer et pourquoi avoir choisi les
panneaux solaires une énergie propre
bah pour deux raisons fin déjà la
première évidemment environnementale et
sait aussi que sinon ça nous faisait
faire beaucoup de travaux donc un gros
impact environnemental pour faire monter
les plus cités jusqu'ici de
l'électricité en quantité suffisante
pour alimenter la peur on a également un
autre système d'énergie propre donc
c'est sûr que les sièges des planètes
en fait le bas de la remontée est
alimenté par un système de cuir fauve en
fait c'est comme un système de dynamos
ça permet d'alimenter la loi
face au réchauffement climatique
certaines initiatives peuvent paraître
anecdotique mais la transition verte des
stations de ski doit prendre en compte
une réalité économique
les sports d'hiver font vivre bons
nombres d'habitants dans les vallées on
travaille dans un environnement naturel
on a besoin de le préserver on peut pas
se permettre peut pas se permettre de
faire n'importe quoi après c'est ce
qu'on appelle du développement durable
c'est à l'économie et l'environnement ça
n'est pas de l'écologie on est dans une
retenue d'eau collinaires elle alimente
les canons à neige la neige artificielle
elle est souvent décrié d'un point de
vue écologique
alors il faut savoir que la neige
artificielle enfin la neige de culture
c'est de l'eau et de l'air rien de plus
il n'y a pas d'abus il n'ya pas
d'adjuvant c'est absolument c'est
strictement interdit en france
nulle part en aucune station vous aurez
des adjuvants donc voilà là une capacité
celle ci devant mille mètres cubes et
donc ça nous permet d'avoir tout le
temps un stock d'eau pour produire la
neige de culture à n'importe quel moment
ça dès que le froid arrive comme ça nous
on a de l'eau pour produire et en quoi
cette retenue d'eau collinaires elle est
peut-être plus respectueuse que d'autres
moyens de stockage pourquoi avoir ce
fait ce choix là va déjà n'y a pas
vraiment d'autres moyens de stockage
pour faire enfin pour avoir suffisamment
de quantité pour produire de la neige de
culture ça évite aussi de prendre de
l'eau du réseau d'eau potable qui
pourraient être prises au détriment des
personnes qui sont dans le village et ça
pourrait poser de gros problèmes
les jets dispose déjà de 130 canons à
neige mais le domaine va en acquérir
d'autres
d'après les experts en 2050 il y aura
60% de neige en moins dans les alpes
françaises
face aux prévisions pessimistes oh j'ai
pas de grandry